soudés coupé cloué une dizaine de jeunes
vies sinois créés dans les ateliers de
la ville comme clara et anaïs 11 ans qui
construisent une horloge j'aime bien
dessiner du coup on m'a dit c'est de
leur place et j'ai du bon ok j'y vais
pour dessiner c'est totalement différent
mais ça m'a beaucoup plu
c'est de dire que par exemple des
touches du clavier ça peut se retrouver
en personnages en france et donner une
nouvelle vie aux objets quoi c'est bien
elle fondu récup art de l'art avec des
objets de récupération
un atelier pensé par la commune et le
conseil municipal des jeunes avec l'aide
du service jeunesse de clerville est et
plus bas de tous les services municipaux
qui ont joué le jeu on a récupéré à la
déchetterie auprès des services aux
fonds au fond de son garage dans un
grenier dans une cave
tous les objets qui étaient destinés à
être mis donc à la déchetterie nous
sommes déjà la ville de l'agglomération
qui est la meilleure élève en terme de
tri puisque nous avons des taux
d'erreurs de tri et les plus bas et des
taux de collecte de déchets recyclables
comme le verre ou les emballages les
plus hauts de l'agglomération elle les
créations seront exposées lors du salon
imagina dès le 7 avril